[Music]
in self incrimination news alright thank
you for that submitted by I am the law
[Laughter]
oh damn and Sylvester Stallone you gotta
watch all their movies that's Robo Cop
he has sex with Sandra Bullock in that
movie without physically touching her
remember he does then Judge Dredd yeah
Joe's right wait is that it
no Troma movie Judge Dredd is the name
of the movie starring Sylvester Stallone
and Sandra look you don't know Judge
Dredd never heard of the minarets those
idiot thieves were immediately arrested
after but dialing 911 oh wow I bet they
were talking about the crime - no but
here's the thing they had to button dial
911 they're ass cheek
individually punched in the three digits
or someone had ordered no there's an
emergency don't you do it ten times or
something like that
Oh may have to press and hold it or at
least free it's a slide right it's a
slide for the Apple watch I think he has
to [ __ ] up his own ass cheeks for being
a little snitch mm-hmm damn he's like
you so now I'm wondering what the crime
was
don't make me catch you with your pants
off what was the crime what was it was
the same yeah what did he do a pair of
burglars of balls they were so big but
dial nine-one-one while they were
fleeing the scene of a burglary at a
Best Buy near Houston at around 3:00
a.m. Houston in Sugar Land Texas that's
so sweet
I know I would love to live there sugar
land I'm sick it's probably hot as [ __ ]
all the houses are made out of candy ooh
perfect sugar no human excess fat smelly
no sugar yeah so they did make off with
very like a lot of valuable merchandise
so cops were responding to the alarm and
best
and around that same time is when they
got this but down and I'm one thing and
then that's when they pinged the cell
phone to find out like where he came
from and it was near that area so they
were quickly arrested you got cop
they should also arrest all the
employees at Best Buy because they were
crooks you should be a class class
action lawsuit against best but every
time I go to Best Buy reminds me why I
don't go to best price tell me well I
have so many problems with electronics
one more [ __ ] employee Best Buy says
I don't know to me the [ __ ] kill
somebody you ask them a question knowing
that you don't want to ask them the
question but got to know anyway and then
they don't know and I'm like what I
hated my best Bible I'm looking at
something right the employer poaches me
and they go do you need any help I go
yes what's this my favorite is when they
have a long conversation while there's a
big long line and then no one goes up to
the register and opens up like another
one it's still one register it's because
they took away their Commission or they
never had it so there's no incentive for
the workers you got to find that one
employee that knows everything about all
the departments for some reason he's
over-enthusiastic
well I think the incentive should be
they lose their job or keep their job
well it's just like maybe don't know it
like I'll go in the other monix
Department I'm like oh I'm looking for
the hero or the GoPro Hero seven does
that battery work with the hero five and
but if it says it in a pocket yeah yeah
let me get back to you yeah and I'm like
isn't this your department what the [ __ ]
you know if you go into like the now
they have the Magnolia TV section like
the home center section it's like for
the all the high-end high-end screens
and sound systems and also those guys
know a little bit more but the problem
with them is they they just try to
upsell the [ __ ] yeah cuz they're like oh
you're in this section you're gonna buy
a $20,000 TV cool they also have like
now with if it's like a very specific
session like your my samsung TV still
have a Samsung Repp there so they're
wrapping the company I really ever Best
Buy you know so it's it that's kind of
dope that's kind of the general camera
shed or anything else that's not in
those they don't know anything dude it's
the worst shopping experience ever they
don't there's no incentives that's why I
just go to pass
for my shopping experience had some
awesome there you just order because I
things I go pro so this is a pest mark
say I missed Circuit City Oh circuit
fever show with a bug in circuit with
the guy that my dad bought the DVD
player from her first DVD player and he
got surround sound system that same
salesman came to our house and hooked it
up I was like where's that guy that's oh
yeah cuz sales used to be a more not
person you knew one like you you were
into it
customer service thingy like I remember
being like this is strange because I
remember Sears and [ __ ] like that I
would go there and Circuit City is now
tigerdirect it's an online thing yeah I
didn't even know they do sexo around yes
RadioShack is still that was like hacker
central why because that's where hackers
went to get like things and and they
macgyver'd things but do they still they
like shut down like 90% of us know I
think a lot of them uncommon there's
still a few around the thieves at Best
Buy do we know what they stole what did
they steal that's an interesting place
to steal things not really because they
carry Apple and a bow really yeah yes by
Dean I haven't gone in a long time yeah
they've GoPros have like I wonder how
they did it because they're like super
secure like did it go to the back I had
to break a door broken but I do know the
aftermath like once the officers were
able to narrow it down like what
happened here this turned into a
high-speed car chase
oh no that reach top speeds of 120 miles
per hour and then eventually it's ended
after approximately 40 minutes him and
then the thieves
bailed from the vehicle and I didn't
know full panic gas huh
they were just running running away and
then law enforcement they always robbed
on a full tank of gas this a helicopter
and can I knew it units so they caught
two of the three suspects the third one
is got a wall of TV this whole time I
was imagining a grab-and-go shoplift
thing and I'm like wow I know but like
my brain just kind of yeah we thought
about the stupid customer service and I
was thinking about guys walk
and grabbing something and then like
there's a high-speed chase versus like
yeah they break in and then they like
take the inventory in the bag I mean
they probably would have found a way if
there wasn't for that Scooby Doo rather
look if it was an inside job because
they had to know where everything was at
that I would get in they did mention
that back in 2015 that same Best Buy was
robbed or $200,000 worth of more tonight
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
iPhones so maybe it is an inside job and
it's the same person doing it I miss
Toys R Us that's what I miss man kids
are missing out right when they were
closing and everything's way more
expensive than an Amazon Amazon even
though they were closing it was still
expensive I'm trying to recoup their
costs I could spend hours at Toys R Us
my parents used to take me there just to
play yeah nobody's there big guy go play
look at all the things I will never buy
you I used to get lost as a child all
the time so like my mom just taught me
how to go up to the customer service and
be like hi I'm - and I'm looking for dr.
Rajan but my mom would never say mrs.
Rizzoli and so like she would just let
me play in the store for like two hours
but the Toys R Us were where I grew up
they used to sell like bikes so they
have like the racks of bikes for kids
and adults and so I just wide the bike
ride around the store
and no one would ever say anything I
feel like now if you did that today the
kid would get clothesline oh for sure
can I be doing where's your mom Jesus
there'd be a lawsuit and like jumping
back straight kick that kid in the face
oh my god that's true that was fun cuz I
would like to like imagine play with all
the toys and I'd save it in my memory
correct and then sometimes my parents
would let me buy the 25 cent thing at
the very end at the register and I'll
get some of them and I get the string
that was slap something that when all
the other kids in the neighborhood had
the dope SuperSoaker
and we checked the most basic one that
was me with power wheel those so cool
dude I want the one those kids they had
the backpack
one name unlimited water hydro tank yes
connect it to the hose if you start
running that kind of slow skin then you
had water balloons used throw it in
their [ __ ] face I had one super
soaker where you can unload the entire
chamber in one shot so like you had like
to squirt then it had a just like a
handle or the bottom handles yeah you
pull the right ingredient or it was
white blue it was a gray blue and orange
and these young bucks get the better
[ __ ] okay I remember I was looking down
like that cuz I mean what like five
years apart that's that's big that's a
lot cuz the toys got better every
[ __ ] year man I feel like the
generation right after me it was when
like oh they're like all super soakers
and toy guns they look they're like
they're too real you gotta change them
and then they became wacky my generation
is when they stopped putting guns and
Toys R Us does no real like looking guns
before they had I thought you just
talked about like real guns no no no
like they had like six shooters and
stuff and revolvers women you could put
the caps yeah yeah yeah but then they
stopped doing it at Toys R Us we used to
have cool [ __ ] like Spears and [ __ ]
bow and arrows and all that done I love
cap guns man ice to shoot them inside
the house was so loud I can still
remember the smell of them when they
would you know if you got a brick and he
smash you it's done like the same noise
why did why did you guys used to have a
Rambo knife I feel like every kid had a
Rambo knife the one with the teeth on
the side yeah I had a machine gun that
you put batteries in and it would
actually recoil oh wait I think it was
electronic it was a movie and I'd run
around I lived in a cul-de-sac there was
like five houses and I just run around
with that thing you definitely couldn't
have done that after 9/11 Oh No
no way dude I had one where it was like
like you hold it with two two hands like
this and it's like just like that okay
and you could put water in there yeah
it's like you couldn't do anything at
least I couldn't do anything after 9/11
do you think no what was your story so
we went to Disney World when I was in
eighth grade four with my school for
marching bands it's like the geekiest
thing you could do would you play so I
played the snare drum but we went I
start soon I was in steel drum band for
like you know the disks kill drums like
the Jamaica island yet so there's
actually like multiple styles of steel
drums they have like the treble on the
bass and so the bass was just a big it
looked like an oil canister yeah anyways
we're coming back and so we're with the
school so there's like a hundred kids
and of course I'm the only kid who's
pulled out random screen check and you
have to understand this I'm like five
feet tall I have glasses braces pimples
and they're like you and I don't know if
you're like why I remember going why and
they were like random Security check I
was like I'm with my [ __ ] middle
school high school like I would have
thought you were Mexican yeah they were
just like who's this ugly Puerto Rican
kids but no post 9/11 now everyone
scared me now when I go through airport
security they're scared no really or
you'll be like no what are you doing
he's like mildly famous let him go yeah
that happened that happened last time I
flew back at home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]